te la senti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovissimo video sono faringei oggi
siamo tornati su parliamo di cose non
sbattiamo il mento sul microfono sono
molto molto contento che vi interessino
i video dove chiacchieriamo di cose
perché quello che l'ultima volta andato
molto bene e parlare con voi mi
veramente è una cosa che mi piace molto
il modo più bello per avvicinarmi a voi
e non credo di aver neanche mai fatto
una cosa del genere da quando faccio
video quindi proprio un'evoluzione
bellissimo parliamo quindi di soldi la
parola soldi genera sempre nel cervello
delle persone che lo ascoltano una sorta
di fano ha detto quella parola soldi
soldi sul muso sede monetizzata parola
soli no perché si parla di soldi allora
andiamo dritti simi al punto senza
girarci intorno i soldi fanno la
felicità
sennò finisce il video subito una bella
faccia parte di spiega dipende è una
risposta un po dei però effettivamente
c'è un motivo se si risponde così e
adesso vi dico io mi sono sempre chiesto
questa cosa ok da quando ero bambino
mela chiedevo sempre io ho vissuto in
una famiglia umile a torino mia mamma
lavorava come
come impiegata in un outlet di vestiti
poi rimasta a casa mio papà invece non
sono mai capire che cacchio fa bene mio
papà comunque installava i tele le reti
telefoniche per le aziende una cosa del
genere si è voluta questa cosa quindi è
poi andato a fare gestione di impianti
bacheca è una famiglia come normale come
tutti e quindi non abbiamo mai navigato
nell'oro ma c'è insomma non stavamo
neanche mai normali ho iniziato a fare
video e i miei video hanno avuto
successo e quindi ho iniziato a fare
sforzi
ok in questa cosa destabilizza sempre
però perché io ho iniziato a lavorare
per conto mio e ho iniziato a mettere
tutto da parte per sempre stato così io
ho dato una risposta ha i soldi danno la
felicità ok la risposta in realtà è più
no che sì dipende da persona a persona
che cos'è per voi la felicità sembra
domanda fatta da progetto happiness che
cos'è quindi per lorenzo che ha messo
dei soldi da parte la felicità per
lorenzo sono io la felicità e la
tranquillità
ok a me di avere uno yacht di fare
viaggi in business ogni 5 minuti in
aereo di prendere i jet privati non me
ne frega niente per carità se capita una
volta ma anche due non è che dico di no
ma non voglio fare di questo la mia vita
perché per me quella non è la felicità
per me la felicità e la tranquillità che
cosa vuol dire vuol dire avere una bella
relazione avere degli amici che ti
vogliono bene di per fare delle proprie
giornate un divertimento sano nel senso
cosa mi va di fare stamattina stamattina
mi va di fare questo e lo vai a fare
oppure stasera non ci ho voglia di
andare in discoteca a spendere 1000 euro
per il tavolo stasera ho voglia di
giocare a dungeons and dragons che i
miei amici non lo faccio da una vita
però vorrei farlo e fatele sopra
richiamo non mi servono soldi per fare
queste cose la mia felicità non è
raggiungibile con il denaro non mi
cambia di molto la vita però uno dice
adesso non ti cambiano come dice gal i
suoi pezzi se non fanno la felicità
d'america beh certo cosa portano i soldi
portano la tranquillità ovvero il fatto
che io faccio un lavoro che mi piace
questa è la mia felicità perché se io
facessi un qualcosa che non mi piace
proprio che non mi che detesto che mi
alzo la tv col no però guadagna un sacco
di soldi la mia vita non avrebbe senso
nel senso che starei fa sarei passando
le giornate a fare un qualcosa che non
mi piace pur guadagnando tanto però
comunque il tempo non lo ridà nessuno e
tu sei sai utilizzando il tuo tempo per
fare una roba che non ti piace quindi
puoi anche essere jeff bezos ma se a
jeff bezos non piace quello che fa la
tua vita è molto migliore di quelli già
facebook ma adesso un esempio dove però
era per farvi che credo che a lui
piaccia quello che fa però era per farvi
capire i nomi cambierei mai con jeff
bezos se sapessi che quello che fa non
mi piace poi non lo so perché non ho mai
fatto il direttore di amazon però per
dirvi non c'è denaro che tenga questa
cosa non esiste non esiste per me ci
sono delle persone invece che
preferiscono farsi il jet privato essere
magari più soli a livello sentimentale
ma farsi il jet ok per loro quella la
felicità quindi per loro io potrei dire
i soldi sono la felicità è per lui
magari sì ma vi dico un'altra cosa ed è
questa e questo il fulcro del video
realtà
quando una persona i soldi a quello che
ha si abitua questa è una cosa molto
sottile ma vera quando tu vivi una
determinata quotidianeità
nella tua vita poi diventa abituale se
tu vivi come stai vivendo adesso perché
è normale vivere così una persona che ha
un sacco di denaro che spende che alla
lamborghini che al jet che sa quel che
vuole
si abitua ad avere quello che vuole e
non è più felice quando ce l'ha cioè voi
pensate che se vuoi ricevere una
lamborghini domani sareste felicissimi
incredibili una lamborghini no pazzesco
wow c'è probabilmente non dormire ste
per settimane dalla felicità se un ricco
sfondato a una lamborghini la notte
dorme tranquillamente come dormiva prima
ok quindi è tutto proporzionato ok ci
sono delle tribù che io non ho avuto mai
la fortuna di incontrare perchè ho
viaggiato ma non così tanto che
sostanzialmente non hanno nulla vivono
nelle capanne eccetera non sanno neanche
cos'è il mondo esterno secondo me loro
sono molto più felici di noi non sono
contaminate da quella che è la società
odierna eccetera quello che rende quello
che si crede che renda felici oggi
perché è luogo comune pensare che sia
così e non hanno niente niente nulla
perché perché vivono così da sempre sono
abituati a vivere così come un come io
mi abituo a vivere come sto vivendo come
un il multimiliardario si abitua vivere
da motivi in tutte le cose tu ti abitui
quindi il denaro non smuove così tanto
gli equilibri il denaro può aiutarti a
renderti la vita più tranquilla non per
tutti tra l'altro forza anzi per la
maggior parte non è neanche così perché
la gente non sa come spendere i soldi ok
tipo quelli che vincono al superenalotto
e spendono tutto in otto anni e poi non
hanno più niente perché non sanno come
gestire quindi ad alcuni non rende
neanche tranquilli questa cosa qua però
secondo me il giusto utilizzo e quello
che faccio io però è una mia opinione è
far sì che non siano i soldi a gestire
la felicità nella tua vita ma che diano
la giusta tranquillità perché quello
alla fine ma che la felicità tu la
prenda da altro totalmente da altro
questo è quello che penso quindi nel mio
caso la felicità non è data dai soldi
quindi questa è la vera risposta che io
con sulla mia pelle ho vissuto questa
cosa quindi
posso da posso dirvi sinceramente quello
che penso ed è questo che la risposta
che avrei voluto da piccolo perché da
piccolo non potevo saperlo e niente
fatemi sapere cosa ne pensate nei
commenti ragazzi come al solito creiamo
un po di dibattito su queste cose perché
mi interessa sapere la vostra opinione
in questi video soprattutto dove sono i
primi dove dialoghiamo veramente ed è
una cosa bellissima giorno l'avevo mai
fatto così tanto forse quando che
raccontava le storie le sue rocket
league ma così tanto mai si conclude qui
il video di oggi iscrivetevi al canale
schiacciate il tasto mi piace se vi è
piaciuto il video è come sempre no ci
vediamo allora bella ragazza
[Musica]
no